how's Cumbres my name's Peter Pat and
welcome to pratapam yes I know it's
Saturday
wait Sunday my load Friday should put a
PI on a Saturday
what is a regular Friday okay oh no no
no it's been a while hi how are you
that's great now back to me so if you
didn't know I turn off the comments
about two weeks ago
for me it was kind of something bound to
happen sooner or later
but I understand it was a shock for many
and many people didn't seem to
understand why but many of you were also
very supportive but I wanted to address
two common misconceptions about it
number one people think I turn off the
comments because I'm tired of haters and
I can't deal with all the trolls in the
ad areata no that's not true
I have my tricks to deal with them why
does no one love me that's besides the
point I've been doing YouTube for four
years I don't care all right
I'm past it but the reason why is
because there was just too much spam the
comments wasn't used to write comments
about the video the comments were used
of other purposes and and most people
were exploiting it so the effect of this
has been that so many of you bros have
been showing support via Twitter or
whatever other means you have and it's
just been really good I feel like this
is the best decisions I made in a long
time which brings me to commit
Concepcion number two which is that he
doesn't care anymore
that's why I turn off the comments which
is actually the opposite if the reason
why I turn off the comments is because I
actually do care I don't know I want
things to get bit better and it had so
I'm super happy and I and I guess number
it goes on number two is that people
seem to think that I am tired of YouTube
and I don't want to do it anymore and
that's why I don't care but no I I loved
making use of videos more than ever now
that I'm not bothered by the YouTube
comments every day so it's been great
I've been loving it and I would just
want to say thank you both so much for
supporting this I know it's a tough
thing to do and like I said it came out
of the blue for many of you I've been
falling in love with making videos again
and that's just been great so thank you
both for your support it means it means
more than you think to me so there you
go
don't take it the wrong way you did it
anyway but I know you bro still want to
comment I know you bros sell money
interact and I want you to keep doing
these things I just don't want it to be
the youtube comment section because it's
[ __ ] awful and everyone knows this we
created bro
my net which is the place for you bros
to connect with each other and comment
as always and we had four months before
but this time I will be active on them
and I just want it to be a place where
you bros can hang out we can communicate
you bros can communicate each other and
just build a good healthy community
around that I think that would be really
cool I think it would be fun for for all
of us so definitely check that out bro
army net I'm gonna link to there each
time I upload a video
for the comments and I'll try and reply
like I've been doing on Twitter the site
is probably crashed already thank you
it's definitely gonna crash let's be
honest here
bros are just too powerful oh yeah it
should be awesome
go there or be not happy in life in
general I like the dramatic shot I have
here would have to have the face being
second news is that we have a t-shirt
you can see it it has like brofist
London it's pretty cool also many
Weaver's have asked for where can i buy
this and now you can so check out the
link in the description for that as well
we have a ton of new shirts for your us
to check out this is definitely my
favorite PewDiePie merch I'm sorry you
can't really see it but uh I think you
boys will like it as well it's cool Tama
bro shirt to show your bonus I say bro
way too much I'm sorry
what do you brothers think is the dwell
lookout no well then there's the door oh
you said yes oh okay I'm sorry the link
is in the description to check that out
that's all for me for now bro you don't
know how much I love you seriously uh I
keep saying it but it means so much to
me that you bros watch my videos every
day despite me being a douche and just
turning off comments like that that's
that's awesome thank you for being a bro
for so long I know a lot of you has been
bro for years so yeah that's all for me
for now that's always bros we're gonna
brofist that's my charge I charge it up
like that how do you do it oh you spin
it
alright we gonna do it oh my back
[ __ ]
uh don't do that peels all right here we
go
Brophy